Course support. You have a few ways of accessing
support while taking these courses on Udacity through Georgia
Tech. Your course forum is going to be your primary
channel for getting support. The forum we used is called
Piazza. You can check it out on piazza.com. After
you enroll and are registered in a class, you'll
be able to access a special course forum dedicated
to you and your classmates taking the class at the
same time. You will sign up to join your
course forum by email, from the instructor or your
TA. You should get this email by the first
day of the semester. After you're signed into Piazza, you
can access the forum through a link next to
the course viewer in the classroom. You can also navigate
directly to piazza.com and access your courses that way.
I'll walk you through the forum later in this lesson.
Each class has its own private forum on
Piazza for each semester. Only the course staff and
your classmates have access to this forum. Your
course staff includes the instructor of record for the
course, the head TA, and additional TAs. On
Piazza they're all categorized as instructors. So while you're
taking your course if you ever have questions about
content or logistics, please post your question in the
forum for the course staff and your classmates to
help answer. You can also post privately to the course
staff, again, on Piazza they're called instructors, if you're
not comfortable sharing your question with the entire class. For
example, if your question includes sensitive information or code
that you're not sure you're supposed to share with classmates.
I'll show you how to do this in the
next few videos. For now, just know that this option
is available. Your TAs for the course will
also be available through office hours. These office hours
should be held every week. Typically we'll use software
like Google Hangouts and On Air to enable live
video conferencing. You'll get more information on how
to access the office hours, and how to set
up for them in each class. Finally, you can
always reach out to your course staff by email.
Each course will have its own support email address, which you can find in
the course material section of the class on Udacity. If you can't find this
email address, just email us at gt-support@udacity.com.
And we will redirect you. If you've
questions regarding academic advising, registration, admissions, payment,
or other Georgia Tech administrative or program inquiries,
please email Georgia Tech directly at omscs.cc.gatech.edu
[BLANK_AUDIO]